time now for seeing and unseen
where we expose the big cultural stories
of the day and for that we turn to fox
news contributor raymond arroyo
raymond joe biden had a meeting with the
president of israel at the white house
today so how did that go
well as expected ben now look i don't
want to prejudice this
but when it's over you tell me how you
feel about those air strikes in syria
over the weekend
take a look and uh and uh
you know the i directed last night's air
strikes
targeting site chiefs by the
iranian-backed
militia group responsible for recent
attacks on
the u.s personnel in iraq i also want to
be clear
as i said my team and i already working
closely with the israeli government
to uh that took officer earlier this
month
poor soul ben it would have been better
to have his defense secretary
or someone else read this stuff he's
clearly having some difficulties
it actually makes you worry about who's
running the show here
then there's that gesture and you know
the media barely covered this event
there's this gesture we've seen before
where biden rings his hands
now that's called perseveration where
people
repeat when they're in decline gestures
or phrases
now look i'm not here to diagnose him
but this is deeply troubling and it's
getting worse
now how do you feel about those syrian
air strikes man so so you're
telling me that in addition to probably
being illegal by any measure
those also might have just been you know
things that just got thrown around
in in certain areas and i got it i got
to tell you it doesn't make me feel good
whatever to say whatever you would say
about it it's it's heartbreaking i mean
there's a part of it that's
heartbreaking but look kim jong-un's
weight loss got more coverage
in the media than this did and this is
far more grave and important
but speaking of inappropriate gestures
ben american hammer thrower bronze
medalist gwen
berry staged her own protest against the
flag
and the national anthem on saturday when
the flag was unfurled
she turned away at first she put her
hands on her hip she rolled her eyes
then she threw her activist athlete
shirt
over her head afterwards barry said i
feel like it was a setup
and they did it on purpose i was pissed
to be honest
raymond how is it a setup to hear the
national anthem
after an olympic event i mean has she
not seen what they typically do
well this is the whole point ben i mean
you know now now the whole country's
pissed and not just her
look when you make a contract you make
good on that contract you follow through
this woman has made a contract she wants
to represent the united states
in the olympics this is her shot and
when she gets there
she disparages and protests against the
country
it's it's just not the right venue for
this look
if professional athletes want to do this
that's one thing this is entirely
different then
it really is well you're representing
the flag obviously the white house
defended
gwenberry today part of that pride in
our country
means recognizing there are moments
where we are as a country haven't lived
up to our highest ideals
and it means respecting the right of
people granted to them in the
constitution to peacefully protest
well they're not here yeah they're not
here to protest they're here to perform
you know and look we remember the
goodwill games ben they used to
ted turner had the goodwill games we
should have the protest games
and they can have the you know the
hundred yard cop chase they can have the
long distance maltal
toss we could do those things there but
these olympic trials
it's not the place for protests i'm
sorry well i also
i just think that when it comes to
performances like this
it's obviously meant to take away from
the fact that she came in third
and and and to actually make that appeal
that make that appeal
you know you forget the fact that colin
kaepernick ranked 34th out of 32
quarterbacks the year that he got
benched
you know it's just the sort of thing
that goes away when you perform in this
manner
you got to get attention somehow this is
how they do it look finally ben the ceo
and president
of the make a wish foundation richard
davis
made an alarming statement about their
post-pandemic wishes late last
week and it's it's really disturbing
which participants including your wish
kid and any siblings
will need to be two weeks past
completion of either a one dose or a two
dose vaccine
now ben the vaccine is only approved for
children over 12 years old these are
terminally ill children
who in some cases cannot take the covet
vaccine
to deny them their wish as they face
eternity
is not only cruel it's frankly absurd
and it cuts against
the entire reason for this make-a-wish
foundation yeah the the foundation is
now clarifying their stance uh saying we
respect everyone's freedom of choice
make a wish will continue to grant
wishes for all eligible children
make a wish will not require anyone to
get vaccinated to receive a wish
i'm glad that they've reconsidered but
this whoever had this idea in the first
place
you know needs needs to really you know
get their head checked but that
statement is a bit deceiving ben because
when you read deeper you realize yeah
they're saying everyone will be
considered to receive a wish however if
you're not vaccinated
there will be no flights there will be
no large gatherings for you
that is cruel since most of these kids
want to go to disney world
that's off the table for them they can
only do a local wish fulfillment
i'm sorry these babies these families
are traumatized
they know what risk is every day of
their lives you let them embrace it
and you let these kids and these
families enjoy their time together
that's why this place exists and i hope
make-a-wish who's done great work in the
past reconsiders this it's a stupid
policy
absolutely and i agree with you raymond
thank you so much for coming on